last week we talked about how bankruptcy
works well this week we learn more about
the three different types of bankruptcy
eric palacios from eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tells us more
welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney
eric palacios although most debts can be
eliminated with the bankruptcy today
we're going to show you three debts that
cannot be eliminated through bankruptcy
number one
tax debt if it's recent in the last
three years you cannot eliminate your
tax debt if it's older than three years
in some instances they can be eliminated
number two student loans the majority of
student loans cannot be eliminated
through a bankruptcy and number three
any debt or judgments that were incurred
through a crime or if you were convicted
of committing fraud this has been the
legal minute don't forget to download my
free app eric palacio's legal app
and you can get more information by
giving eric palacios and associates a
call at that phone number 702-444-7777
[Music]